Vous devez être déconcertés de voir que certains adolescents travaillent bien,
sont capitaine de leur équipe,
font du volontariat,
mais avalent de la lessive pour un challenge en ligne
roulent vite et envoient des SMS en conduisant,
boivent trop et prennent des drogues.
Comment autant d'ados peuvent-ils être intelligents et responsables
et en même temps prendre des risques inconsidérés ?
Quand j'avais 16 ans,
quand j'observais mes camarades en vrai
et sur les réseaux sociaux,
je me demandais pourquoi autant d'entre eux prenaient autant de risques.
A croire qu'ils avaient oublié leurs cours de conduite en CM2.
(Rires)
Plus interpelant encore,
plus ils s'exposaient à ces risques,
plus il leur était facile d'en prendre.
Ça me perturbait,
mais ça m'a aussi rendue curieuse.
En tant que personne dont le nom
signifie littéralement « explorer le savoir »,
j'ai commencé à chercher une explication scientifique.
Ce n'est pas un secret que les adolescents de 13 à 18 ans
sont plus enclins à prendre des risques que les enfants et adultes,
mais qu'est-ce qui les rend ainsi ?
Est-ce qu'ils deviennent imprudents,
ou est-ce juste une phase normale qu'ils traversent ?
Les neuroscientifiques ont prouvé
que le cerveau des adolescents est encore en développement
et que cela nuit à leur prise de décision,
les poussant à adopter des comportements à risques.
Mais, si le développement cérébral est à blâmer,
pourquoi les ados sont-ils plus vulnérables que les enfants
alors que leur cerveau est plus développé ?
De plus, tous les adolescents ne prennent pas le même niveau de risques.
Y a-t-il des causes inconscientes et sous-jacentes qui les poussent
à prendre des risques ?
C'est ce que j'ai décidé de chercher.
J'ai basé ma recherche sur la base du processus psychologique
appelé « accoutumance »,
ce qu'on appelle simplement « s'habituer ».
L'accoutumance explique comment notre cerveau s'adapte à certaines conduites
comme mentir à répétition.
Ce concept m'a inspiré le projet
de déterminer si le même principe
pouvait s'appliquait à l'escalade des risques pris par les adolescents.
J'ai fait l'hypothèse que l'accoutumance au risque
modifiait le cerveau déjà vulnérable des adolescents
en neutralisant ou même supprimant
les émotions négatives associées au risque,
comme peur et culpabilité.
Comme ils ressentiraient moins de peur et culpabilité,
cette désensibilisation les conduirait à plus de prises de risques.
En gros, je voulais conduire une recherche
répondant à une grande question :
pourquoi les ados font-ils encore et encore des choix
qui nuisent à leur santé et leur bien-être ?
Mais il y avait un obstacle sur mon chemin.
Pour étudier ce problème,
j'avais besoin d'adolescents,
de laboratoires et d'outils de mesure de leur activité cérébrale,
et de professeurs pour m'accompagner.
J'avais besoin de ressources.
Mais je suis allée dans un lycée du Dakota du Sud
avec peu d'opportunités pour les recherches scientifiques.
Mon lycée proposait athlétisme,
des groupes de musique, une chorale, des groupes de débat
mais pas de programme scientifique ou de mentors pour la recherche.
Et l'idée que des lycéens
participent à des recherches scientifiques était très obscure.
Je n'avais tout simplement pas les ingrédients
pour faire un plat digne d'un chef.
Ces obstacles me frustraient,
mais j'étais une adolescente bornée.
En tant que fille d'immigrés bangladais
et une parmi le peu d'étudiants musulmans
de mon lycée du Dakota du Sud,
j'ai souvent eu du mal à m'intégrer.
Et je voulais apporter quelque chose à la société,
pas seulement être étiquetée comme la brune aux foulards,
l'anomalie de ma ville sans histoire.
J'espérais qu'avec cette recherche,
je pourrais implanter ça
mais aussi à quel point la recherche peut être bénéfique pour les jeunes comme moi
qui n'ont pas encore trouvé leur place.
Alors, avec peu de moyens,
la créativité m'a permis de dépasser les obstacles.
Je suis devenue plus créative en travaillant avec plusieurs méthodes,
matériels et sujets.
J'ai transformé mon modeste CDI
en laboratoire
et mes pairs en rats de laboratoire.
(Rires)
Mon enthousiaste prof de géographie,
qui était aussi le coach de football de mon lycée,
est devenu mon champion,
mon mentor pour les formalités administratives.
Quand il a fallu utiliser
un électroencéphalographe de laboratoire,
ou EEG,
qui mesurent les réponses émotionnelles avec des électrodes,
j'ai acheté avec mes propres sous, un casque d'EEG,
plutôt que le nouvel iPhone X
pour lequel beaucoup de mon âge économisaient.
J'ai finalement commencé ma recherche
avec 86 étudiants de mon lycée, âgés de 13 à 18 ans.
Avec les ordinateurs du CDI de mon lycée,
je leur ai fait compléter une simulation de prise de décision
pour mesurer leur enclin à prendre des risques par rapport au monde extérieur,
notamment la consommation d'alcool, de drogue, ou le jeu d'argent.
En portant le casque d'EEG,
les étudiants ont fait ce test 12 fois en 3 jours
pour mimer l'exposition répétée au risque.
Un EEG de contrôle
mesurait leurs réponses émotionnelles :
attention, intérêt, excitation, frustration,
culpabilité, niveau de stress et de relaxation.
Ils ont aussi noté leurs émotions
sur une échelle de mesure validée.
J'ai donc mesuré le processus d'accoutumance
et ses effets sur la prise de décision.
Il a fallu 29 jours pour venir à bout de cette recherche.
Après des mois de frénétiques rédactions de protocoles,
de traitement de données à 2h du matin, droguée à la caféine,
je pouvais enfin conclure.
Les résultats ont montré que l'accoutumance au risque
pouvait modifier le cerveau des ados en altérant leurs réponses émotionnelles,
les poussant à en prendre plus.
Les émotions normalement associées au risque
comme la peur, le stress, la culpabilité, la nervosité,
ou encore l'attention,
étaient élevées lors de la première simulation.
Cela a réduit leur attirance et renforcé leur maîtrise d'eux-mêmes,
les empêchant de prendre plus de risques.
Néanmoins, plus ils étaient exposés au risque à travers le simulateur,
moins ils se sentaient craintifs, coupables et stressés.
Finalement,
ils n'étaient plus capables de ressentir
la peur et la prudence normales.
Aussi, parce que ce sont des adolescents, avec des cerveaux sous-développés,
ils sont devenus de plus en plus attirés par les sensations fortes.
Quels en furent les effets ?
Ils manquaient de contrôle dans leurs prises de décisions,
prenaient de plus grands risques
et faisaient plus de choix dangereux.
Ce n'est donc pas seulement le cerveau en développement qui est en cause.
Le processus d'accoutumance joue aussi un rôle majeur dans la prise de risque
et l'escalade du risque.
Si la volonté de prendre des risques des ados
dépend largement des modifications structurales et fonctionnelles
associées au développement cérébral,
le danger que ma recherche a mis en évidence
est que l'accoutumance au risque
peut physiquement changer le cerveau d'un adolescent,
les poussant à en prendre plus.
C'est la combinaison d'un cerveau immature
et de l'accoutumance
qui arrive comme une tornade pour créer plus de dommages.
Cette recherche peut aider les parents et le public
à comprendre que les ados n'ignorent pas juste les avertissements
ou défient l'autorité en s'engageant dans des comportements toujours plus dangereux.
Leur plus grand obstacle est leur accoutumance au risque :
tous les changements physiques et émotionnels
qui commandent, contrôlent et influencent leurs excessives prises de risques.
Alors oui, nous avons besoin de mesures pour offrir un environnement plus sûr
et limiter l'exposition aux hauts risques,
mais nous avons aussi besoin de mesures reflétant mes découvertes.
Ces résultats sont aussi une alarme pour les adolescents.
Ça leur montre que la peur et la culpabilité naturelles
qui les protègent des situations dangereuses
peuvent disparaitre avec la répétition de prises de risques.
Avec l'espoir de partager mes découvertes avec d'autres ados et scientifiques,
j'ai envoyé ma recherche
au Intel International Science and Engineering Fair (ISEF),
qui regroupe plus de 1 800 étudiants
de 75 pays, régions et territoires,
qui présentent leurs recherches et inventions de pointe.
Ce sont les Jeux Olympiques des sciences.
(Rires)
J'ai alors pu présenter ma recherche à des experts en neurosciences et psychologie
et avoir un retour de qualité.
Mais le moment le plus mémorable de la semaine
a été quand les haut-parleurs ont hurlé mon nom
pendant la remise des prix.
J'étais tellement stupéfaite que je me suis demandé
si ce n'était pas encore une erreur genre « La La Land »
comme pendant les Oscars.
(Rires)
Heureusement, ce n'en était pas une.
J'avais vraiment obtenu le premier prix
en « Sciences Sociales et Comportementales ».
(Applaudissements)
Inutile de dire
que j'étais non seulement ravie de cette consécration,
mais aussi que cette expérience de concours
m'a permis de garder ma curiosité vivante
et de renforcer ma créativité,
ma persévérance et mon imagination.
Cette image de moi expérimentant au CDI
peut paraître ordinaire,
mais pour moi, c'est une source d'inspiration.
Elle me rappelle que ce processus m'a appris à prendre des risques.
Et je sais que cela peut sembler ironique.
Mais j'ai pris des risques en réalisant
que des opportunités imprévues viennent souvent de prises de risques,
pas dangereux et délétères comme ceux que j'ai étudiés,
mais les bons,
les bénéfiques.
Plus j'ai pris de risques,
plus je me suis sentie capable de gérer des situations inhabituelles,
de faire preuve de tolérance, de ténacité et de patience
dans mes projets.
Ces leçons m'ont amenée à de nouvelles idées :
est-ce aussi vrai avec l'opposé des prises de risques délétères ?
Y a-t-il une escalade de prise de risques bénéfiques avec l'exposition ?
Les actions bénéfiques amènent-elles à un fonctionnement positif du cerveau ?
Je pense que je viens de trouver mon prochain sujet de recherche.
(Applaudissements)